des pots-de-vin pour être admis à un
concours accélérer l'obtention d'un
passeport ou se voir délivrer un faux
permis de conduire la corruption affecte
tous les pans de la vie quotidienne
c'est le constat amer de ses habitants
de yopougon l'une des communes les plus
peuplées du district d'abidjan c'est pas
tout à fait c'est pas tout suivi d'un
peu de soupe est bonne tout passe via
les médicaments qui sont prescrits sur
ordonnance et il faudrait forcément
d'abord voit la maladie a vendu à bâle
d'obtenir cette ordonnance mais avec un
peu d'argent bon petit donne ici on peut
des données lors de noces est donc
abaissée être comme ça tu donnais
pougatchev c'est la pharmacie ou avalé
beaucoup maintenant on demande certaines
choses
bien trop de corruption il faut que
l'état revoie il s'arrache aucun doute
nous qui sommes jeunes nous puissions
avoir un boulot l'opinion est épanoui en
fait le policier bon j'ai pas dit qu'ils
voient ils font pas le travail en tant
que telle on y travaille on travaille
faisant ils prennent de l'âge
normalement look caen ouvre vous arrêter
quelqu'un vous devez donner un papier
mais elle a l'impression qu'il est là il
faut que ton lieu de l'argent même si tu
as raison tout n'a pas raison tu dois
donner de l'argent la côte d'ivoire est
classée 104e sur 180 en matière de
corruption par l'omg transparancy
international
le gouvernement dit vouloir combattre ce
fléau généralisé est de plus en plus
dénoncée par les citoyens un ministère a
même été créé pour lutter contre le
racket et restaurer la confiance entre
la population et l'état nous sommes en
train de mettre en place une plate forme
de signalement des cas de corruption ou
les usages et les populations les
personnes intéressées tous ceux qui sont
témoins victimes et qui ont intérêt à ce
que la collection s'arrête donc une
plateforme où toutes ces personnes
peuvent aller et signaler les cas de
corruption est pas d hier
l'équipe du ministère va faire la
vérification des actions fortes ont été
menées dans plusieurs secteurs
problématiques et plus particulièrement
au sein de la police et la gendarmerie
mais pour cette organisation de la
société civile la guerre contre la
corruption est loin d'être gagné c'est
tout un système qui est gangréné il y a
au moins cet ivoirien / / / 10 qui
estime que le gouvernement
n'aborde pas bien la question de la
corruption et la plupart d'entre eux
fustigé le manque de sanctions que ce
soit au niveau au niveau judiciaire du
système judiciaire ce soit au niveau du
gouvernement ou au niveau 2
je veux dire du parlement de la présence
d'amélie et des régies financières
ils les enquêtes montrent bien que c'est
la corruption n'est pas qu'un secteur
dans une enquête publiée en 2010 cette
part l'institut afrobaromètre un
ivoirien sur deux déclare payé des
pots-de-vin aux forces de l'ordre et un
sur trois reconnaît avoir déjà payé des
agents administratifs pour obtenir des
documents